let's get into halo wars 2 so all three
of us are big Halo fans shooter fans in
general um been working Rob you and I've
been working together for a year and a
half and we probably talk about halo
maybe once a week show some respect yeah
uh and then Cal I know you like a lot of
shooters and love halo so much yes okay
so you're in good company yes um you've
been playing halo words to right we
can't completely talk about everything
we can't talk too much about story the
review will be up tomorrow so look out
for that on gamespot com a cool website
that you may have heard of before um but
I do want to touch on some of the
gameplay stuff for Halo fans I see a lot
of I'm not parallels but kind of where
it takes its inspiration from different
halo missions yeah um so like there's
just stuff that feels like the Warthog
run you know and like AB I'm I've been
enjoying that a lot and the halo nods
and being like oh yeah this is like so
badass like I get those flashbacks in my
first play combat evolved and I was like
this is the best good um and then the
RTS elements almost take a backseat for
me which is it I guess it depends what
you're looking for me but these I was
able to just kind of breeze through a
lot of things just like highlighting all
of my units and family all right go over
there Jesus yeah speaking as someone who
loves halo and RTS I played about half
of the campaign of Halo or student I
completely agree with you that it takes
a lot of nods from not just like halo
campaign but like shooters and I think
you know the question is always is this
an RTS game for Halo fans or halo game
for RTS fans and I think it's the former
it is absolutely the RTS game for Halo
fans because there are a lot of things
even the new multiplayer modes like
blitz and domination yeah are very much
kind of these things you're used to in
shooters they're the right zone control
very fast paced jump in jump out modes
that RTS fans might not traditionally be
used to they work well in the RTS
structure and kind of change of how you
play yeah but they are very accessible
for someone I could immediately look at
domination be like oh I've played a lot
of Halo 3 in my time I kind of get how
this works I'm going to send these units
to hear
capture it exact offended a little bit
move to the next one get resources um
but like you said the Warthog run from
the end of halo 1 and 3 is like the
first mission in this game it's not
really a spoiler it's just it's showing
you how around units but it's also like
I love that it functions as a tutorial
essentially if I was trying to imagine
it like an RTS yeah you have a single
word hog hog if you skip the tutorial
which don't cuz you get an achievement
for it if you care about that um I do um
yeah it's it's just like here's how you
move around the map but it's it reminded
me so much of the the Warthog run and
yeah you're just controlling a single
warthog through an environment and just
following kind of waypoints and the the
one thing like a big gripe I have is you
can't zoom out very far and I just yeah
I always felt like I couldn't get a good
enough view of the battlefield
especially later on um but you know the
other perspective almost feels more like
an isometric game rather than a I mean
it's it is I symmetric and a lost by it
feels more like a dungeon crawler
sometimes when you're looking at it than
an RTS that you can zoom out well yeah
and like zooming in I never zoomed in I
stayed almost at that's funny that he's
a man on the stuff um I almost always
was fully zoomed out yeah playing I just
didn't need to be zoomed unless you
wanted to like see something up close I
love grunts so I saw a grunt once knows
like that's my best friend there garbled
so Larry there look like a the name of
the move in halo is ground pound yes
yeah there are like the Spartans again
the Spartans of the heroes with a lot of
RTS have these abilities but Spartans
can kind of do stuff like that you know
the other spartan laser obviously you'll
recognize the weapons if you played a
lot of halo they're also the mission
structure feels very influenced by like
a halo campaign like on the time i
played there's a boss fight it in an RTS
absolutely i mean we shouldn't get too
too into it but um it's absolutely like
if like a halo game will go from like
guns blazing to you got to be super
careful and watch yourself and this felt
a lot like that that's so funny you know
hearing you talk about it uh it's like
okay yeah i could see halo influences
but this map is totally
combat Evolved the second map when you
land halo um yeah oh yeah the first one
that's totally get what you get to kind
of exploring there's there are other
missions that just even the name it's
taken from the first halo um like a
beachhead and then you kind of rush up
it again I don't spoil anything but yeah
there's skulls you can get skulls yeah
if you do secondary Jack do you get
skulls yeah this is very much the
question I wanted to ask because we can
set up the premise right of the story
pretty quickly no we can't we can't
there's like a thing at the very
beginning that like yeah we can't really
talk about though the premise there is
part of the premise is that there is a
rogue brute faction called the banished
and that's who you're up against here
rattling about when this takes place
covenant yes after five yeah so it's
it's a 28 years after halo wars won I
believe you know 28 of 28 28 um sweet we
can know that yes but um this is this is
the one where it gets yeah tricky
because I wants plenty thing but it is
even the story itself kind of bookends
things that happen in the halo storyline
and I think like I said is halo wars two
essential for a halo fan and essentials
a strong word but I think if you are a
halo fan and you have some passing
interests in RTS and flushing of the
story I think it's worth your time it is
a barebone RTS I don't like Starcraft
fans or Warcraft 3 fans might not love
this but it does flush out the story in
a great way and I think it actually like
i said is accessible if you just have
played the halo shooter so I like Rob I
could see you getting into this yeah I'd
you play many RTS games right it's super
accessible i will say i do like RTS i
mean i like like Ehlert too yes games
ever you've starcraft Warcraft to like
definitely into it um yeah I honestly
was not inclined to play this but just I
guess the nostalgia factor would maybe
pull me in more than I thought when you
were talking about I was like okay yeah
you know I want up you want to enjoy the
game yeah the day right and but there's
still something about halo that can
still learn me in there's always going
to be something at halo even the
cinematics which I won't say the subject
of
but um even then I'm like watching them
being like I just [ __ ] love halo so
much definitely on fanservice blur
studios i believe did the cutscenes
right they did the halo 2 anniversary
cutscenes yeah yeah yes what probably
most gorgeous cutscenes outside of like
blizzard games these are the best
looking cuts days ever look great yeah
and so I was just it felt like very
directed at me as a halo fan in general
and I think you know it's a very simple
interface for an RTS it's kind of like a
two button the tax system same with the
first one so in that sense it's very
accessible i did find myself um like
trying to mash x which is like the
attack but just because I was so used to
having like I'm like a attacked shoot
now and that's obviously not how it
works and so I had to untrain my brain
out of that have you been using control
groups at all with like I think you can
map them to d pad so you can just group
like the hellburners together and then
the Marines together in a different
group yeah I wish it were more specific
like I wish I could assign like a custom
group like oh I'm gonna have you know
two warthogs that's some help ringers oh
that's a bummer yeah yeah like a cyclops
and um it's building on pc i played on
pc yet i haven't been playing on xbox
just to clarify it does work well on pc
you can have like a warthog a hella
bringer a Spartan but yeah I'm
controllers right you fit w happy unit
and then map like every marine on screen
to one group or something yeah it's it's
completely I mean honestly I haven't
really had to bother with that much yes
not I'm playing on normal for the
purposes of the review so when I play it
through and a higher difficulty that's
probably not going to be the case but
for you know just for anyone who's
playing on the average difficulty I
don't think that's going to be even
really necessary um I was basically like
just paint highlighting units and
sending them to where I needed them and
it was almost there were times right I
finished a mission like I won the
mission thy was like oh it's over all
right okay I did it oops that was my
impression from playing about half the
campaign on PC is that when I actually
tried to be really tactical and RTS
minded and have the hell bringers you
know hit this garrison the Spartan
Jerome and the Marines hit this building
while my wart hog shooted this it didn't
feel like that was completely necessary
like I'm
might be like duh you know dividing up
attacks attack groups when you're going
for base and you know like red alert or
Starcraft or Warcraft it felt like I was
trying to do too much for an RTS that
didn't want me to think that much and
that comes into your your comment about
being accessible it feels like if i
invade abase an army yeah it helps to
kind of divide up what they're doing but
after a while it just kind of devolves
into everybody shoot this thing and then
all of you shoot this thing and then
once that's done everybody shoot at this
thing throw grenades yeah I there were
there were some instances where that's
not the case but yeah if the if there's
more like I'm gonna as soon as we're
done here I'm gonna go play more so if
there's more customization that would be
cool haven't even had to bother looking
for it so in general what's your take if
you're a halo fan should you play this I
mean I'm sure people will go on youtube
and just watch all the cutscenes to get
the story but yeah I mean yeah if you
really really don't want to play an RTS
then yeah sure read those plot synopsis
I guess with like I can't force you to
play it but I would say it's definitely
an RTS for Halo fans like you said not a
halo game prior to it irts fans but if
you would like more detailed information
you can check out my review tomorrow yes
gamespot also has a few V feature videos
up Nick margarita did some stuff on Halo
Wars 2 he went up to three for three
studios recently did a couple interviews
put up a few feature videos oh speaking
of Nick margarita he wants to talk about
us to talk about the Blitz mode you want
to I mean we can I your kind of run
about blitz mother um so blitz correct
me if I'm wrong is the card the deck
building yeah mode so you can in
campaign if you rank up right maybe it
carries over into skirmish but you have
these decks see these cards kind of like
any deck-building Game and you get to
pick start forming your deck and bring
it into blitz mode and you play these
decks at the same time so someone like
Nick margarita was saying he'll bring a
bunch of cheaper cards like ODSTs would
be 80 Marines would be 60 or something
he'd bring a bunch of those and then two
really strong cards like a Mack blast or
a scorpion tank and then bring those in
it kind of just affects what you are
bringing into the fight yeah it's like
an RTS twist on blitz which i think is
an interesting concept and for sure
so that's that's pretty cool in that you
can rank up and unlock new cards in
campaign across cross-play thing between
campaign and multiplayer but yeah like I
said it's kind of bringing a few
different genres how they have deck
building in this I think of that what
you will I like the bridging between
campaign and multiplayer because that's
something that some games just drop
completely I always appreciate an effort
put there I will say yeah but you know
cool yeah awesome so uh yeah Kelly your
review will be up soon as Jason this
week I got to go right yeah we'll let
you get back it after the show he'll be
up and then like I said we have video
features up on gamespy you go check
those out and yeah stay tuned to gain
Swofford rest the week for more halo
wars 2 coverage and for the review and
to see our final thoughts I like it I'm
having fun with it so far I think Robbie
think you should try it out maybe as a
halo fan cool yeah maybe I'll walk it
out I just might
[Music]